ah
[Música]
en julio de este año 210 mil migrantes
cruzaron la frontera entre méxico y eeuu
la cifra mensual más alta en los últimos
20 años la oposición republicana que se
opone a muchas de las medidas de
precaución contra el virus está culpando
la política migratoria de bailén de la
reciente ola de contagios respecto al
gobierno de bailén está considerando
vacunar a los inmigrantes indocumentados
que esperan su deportación en centros de
reclusión y aquellos que esperan su
audiencia en la corte para definir su
aplicación de asilo la medida de
vacunación con johnson y johnson no
incluye a los migrantes que son
deportados inmediatamente a méxico oa
sus países bajo la ley de salud pública
título 42 una regulación de trump que
mantuvo vaivén y que le permite deportar
al instante a personas indocumentadas
que la patrulla fronteriza considera
como una amenaza de salud pública para
los estadounidenses
en italia según la fundación umberto
veronesi serían 600.000 las personas en
condición de irregularidad 50 mil
adicionales sin techo y 200.000 habrían
solicitado la regularización pero
todavía no tienen respuesta dentro del
plan del gobierno se prevé alcanzar la
inmunidad de rebaño con un 80 por ciento
de la población italiana vacunada para
el mes de septiembre pero dentro de
estas cifras no se cuenta a los
irregulares lo cierto es que a pesar del
llamado de la agencia italiana del
fármaco del propio comisario para la
emergencia francisco filólogo lo cierto
es que todavía no se ha generado un plan
nacional de vacunación el vaticano la
fundación sant editó fundación cáritas
han generado planes de vacunación para
estas personas en condiciones de
irregularidad pero los sistemas de
sanidad regionales que son
independientes todavía se mueven a
velocidades distintas no se sabe todavía
a ciencia cierta una cifra sobre la
vacunación en este grupo de personas
irregulares o vulnerables en italia
costa rica- vacunará contra la cob y 19
a las personas indocumentadas así lo
aseguró el presidente carlos alvarado
que ante la consulta de los medios dijo
que hay una solución que trabaja la
cancillería y el ministerio de salud en
este país de 5 millones de habitantes al
menos el 10% de la población es
extranjera la gran mayoría de nicaragua
según un diagnóstico migratorio de 2017
aquí viven 350.000 nicaragüenses a los
que habría que agregar entre 100.000 y
200.000 en condición migratoria
irregular además desde 2018 decenas de
miles de nicaragüenses han solicitado
refugio en costa rica tras el estallido
de una crisis en nicaragua también a
inmigrantes de colombia el salvador y
eeuu
diversos sectores insisten en la
importancia de vacunar a todos los
habitantes para lograr la ansiada
inmunidad de rebaño en costa rica más de
la mitad de la población ya tiene al
menos una dosis de la vacuna las
autoridades aún no dicen cuándo
empezarían a vacunar a la población
indocumentada pero dejaron entrever que
lo harían gracias a un donativo
[Música]